la chanteuse céline dion est la plus
connue des québécoises aux états unis
espèrent le devenir tout autant en
france elle donnera trois concerts
l'olympia à partir de demain
cécile barnier qui étaient aux champs
elysées a fait un détour par les grands
boulevards pour la rencontrer en
répétition répétition à l'olympia elle a
chanté sur cette scène il ya dix ans et
puis le public français l'avait un peu
boudé redécouverte avec l'album des mots
qui sonnent et ziggy de starmania
céline dion est de retour
dans sa tête et à la poussière
il vendait discutant outil on dirait
qu'ils aient vu dans une autre cas
véritable star au québec son dernier
album s'est vendu à 2 millions
d'exemplaires aux états unis un coup de
force pour une chanteuse francophone
mais il aurait fallu passer par des
textes en anglais
c'est avec un disque en anglais en leur
disant we wish québécoise francophone
mais ça me plaît beaucoup de charles
dang est plein ils ont commencé à dire
ce que tu nous chanter une chanson en
français oui avec plaisir
alors là quand je fais un tour de change
leur chambre quelques chansons en
français
ils sont comme ça il adore ça mais si
j'avais fait le contraire en disant mais
moi je suis francophone vous n'acceptez
comme ça vous met cette époque c'est pas
comme ça c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
attaquer les gens qu'il faut ça ne
marche pas comme ça
st
échauffement m
chopin
un sou
avec les
m
elle est prêt
qui composent aînés